famously obviously you were a carpenter
when you started out I started out as an
actor and I became a carpenter because I
didn't like the kind of work I was so do
you still do carpentry do you still not
so much like so many poncey actors you
see like you know they go and maybe
after film you know I need to go home
and have a bath and maybe read some
poetry to unwind but Harrison when the
director shouts car probably opens a can
of beer then builds a [__] shed
I didn't I don't know how I miss I don't
know how I missed this aspect of hair
support type so it's not just the shed
building you know other interests end of
October it seems like that's a very
exciting time to be around the Ford
Flockhart household Halloween Halloween
this has become a big thing for you how
do we know you push the boat out here's
you and yeah you look scary like a woman
I had a one-night stand with him Wiggin
and was me
are you a fan of Kim and Kanye or do you
hate them
no I love I mean Kim Kardashian has you
know her I'm she's a nice person
I like weird sex faces oh no that's not
a weird sex face but you know shoot she
yes she's a bit of a weird catch it's
not you know it was directed by